hey Outlander fans I'm Lea regular with
Entertainment Tonight and I'm here with
the brand new person to the Outlander
cast is our Dom boy who you might
recognize him because he looks a lot
like younger Fergus cuz he's playing
older Fergus yeah well exactly how crazy
is that for you to be coming on to a
show where there was already a younger
version of yourself it's weird in the
best way it's such a great thing to
start working on you know it's the first
time actually I'm I'm catching someone
else's part and young Fergus was so good
that it's actually I'm really happy that
I have to be as good as he was and just
like trying to keep like doing what he
was doing in the show now were there
certain mannerisms that you watched from
the actor playing younger Fergus that
you've tried to incorporate into your
own portrayal yeah you remember how he's
always leaving his hands like Oliver
like a pickpocket you know trying to
feel the shapes off of everything around
him or maybe trying to find a spot to
steal something that's something I
thought was lovely so I'm trying to to
do stuff like he was doing moving like
he was in being enthusiastic and I think
the same emoji face you know what I mean
and also add some more of grown-up
Fergus because we can imagine a lot can
happen those 15 years of gap well and
you know younger Fergus was always very
attuned with the ladies yeah he always
kind of could see behind what they were
initially thinking so do you feel like
that's kind of helped him in his love
life in the future oh you know love life
at that time was very particular because
I don't think Fergus hasn't made a lot
of women actually so but he was born and
raised in the in a brothel so it gave
him probably some kind of special
relationship and know it about women
no yeah thing yeah definitely well thank
you so much for sitting down with me I
really appreciate it you so much for
having me of course and for all you fans
out there for all the latest and
Meishan be sure to follow Outlander on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram bye
you